[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery infinity war review
as you would expect it was totally crazy
but don't worry no spoilers in this
video there are a couple things that
people will walk out of this movie
talking about in particular one is
Thanos his performance the way they
ended the film the post-credits scene
and then the way that they fit all these
crazy parts together because the
structure of the movie is very different
from a traditional Marvel movie which
once you see it will make you understand
why other filmmakers and other Studios
don't try to do movies that are this big
like they just fall right on their face
with the Russos pulled off a crazy hat
trick so if you are brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos it's all gonna be non
spoilery till the end of the week
there's giveaway stuff going on that
I'll explain at the end of the video too
but you're starting with the big bullet
points first it feels like the Russos in
Kevin Feige wanted to do their version
of Empire Strikes Back because it's
supposed to be Thanos film he's kind of
like the Darth Vader of the Marvel
Universe and if you know the full story
of Darth Vader of anakin skywalker's
fall from grace they do try to give fan
oohs a back story that makes him feel
much sadder is a character but if you
know his comic book backstory all say is
that it's a little bit different so be
prepared for that but I believe that
there were a couple interviews where the
Russo said that this wasn't anything
like the infinity saga so that includes
the Infinity Gauntlet thanos quest all
these big comic book arcs there are a
lot of big moments from those comic
books that anchor the film at various
points so if you have read those
recently you will recognize that stuff
but the clever thing that they did in
marketing this movie is is that the
trailers that they've given us are
really like less than five minutes of
total footage in there's some blatantly
misleading stuff Varick about very big
literally in metaphoric lead moments
that don't appear anywhere during the
movie so you're like ah
they pulled a thor ragnarok on us again
but I think the real magic of the film
is in all the character moments in the
pairings that they have so that's really
what they're using to sell this like
everybody knows about the Infinity
stones everybody knows about Santos and
the Infinity Gauntlet but really they're
trying to sell you on like this Winter
Soldier Wakanda Captain America Iron Man
and Doctor Strange together like what's
that like Thor with the Guardians hands
down
pairings worth or with the Guardians
that was just absolute magic and then
you know literal magic with Iron Man and
Doctor Strange so we don't want to say
there were any bad pairings in the film
but some of them were sublime some of
them were matches made in heaven why
haven't they done this before and some
were just really really good but that
sort of gets into the structure of the
film which I feel like some people are
started to criticize the movie for even
though I think the Russos did a great
job of featuring all these characters
you just have to go into it remembering
that this is not the Avengers film this
is thanasis film so even though like
they're focusing on all the Avengers
characters and the different pairings
and all the trailers really the
perspective you're meant to take is
Thanos going around on his heist for the
Infinity stones so when you think about
it that way they actually did end the
movie in a really awesome way you know
no spoilers for the ending because
that's all people are gonna be talking
about later this week don't worry
there'll be a lot to unpack which is why
Kevin Feige said that they're not doing
a Marvel panel this year at Comic Con we
want to get more people time to process
what happens at the end of infinity war
but it definitely had one of the best if
not the best post credit scene of all
time and no spoilers but there's only
one post credit scene
make sure you stay after all the credits
just to talk about the characters and
the performances like they've been
focusing on some characters in
particular like Robert Downey jr. is
always prominently featured in all these
because he's one of the main actors
Captain America Thor the Guardians so
hands down best performance like I said
was Josh Brolin as Thanos it was great
he was probably one of the critical
points of the film if they nose didn't
work the film would have a big problem
and I'd be like they totally nailed the
Thanos character a lot of that goes in
to the visual effects like the artists
that construct him physically and then
Josh Brolin performing the character but
like I said they took some liberties
with his backstory so it's not a one to
one adaptation there's just like some
really big tentpole moments from the
infinity saga that connect his character
to what's going on during the film Chris
Hemsworth was amazing as Thor if there
were any worries that you had about them
sort of rolling his character back or
him being a lesser version of himself
from the end of thor ragnarok forget
about that he's spectacular
it's amazing Chris Evans is Captain
America is on fire the entire movie in
spider-man everything about that
character was
the suit the way that they used him in
the scenes to sort of defuse the moment
he's just so happy to be there like you
look at his face as you would expect
they sort of use him as the audience
surrogates so he just like oh my god
this is amazing the whole time there
were a lot of very notable secondary
characters and cameos that they all used
in very appropriate ways like this is
the best version of what they could do
with this person in this movie if you
are seeing it for the first time just
because you might wind up missing some
of the people if you go to the bathroom
don't drink the large drink right before
the movie starts maybe do that like the
second or third time that you see the
movie one of the few complaints that I
think that the movie will get especially
after a black panther blew up so big is
it's not quite as much of those
characters as people would have expected
given the way they're featured in the
trailers but like I said that just goes
back to them cutting misleading trailers
so what you've seen so far is not an
accurate representation of how much each
of these characters is in this film
there were a couple minor things that
didn't work quite as well as I hope they
would like the black order from a CG
perspective I mean really cool idea but
just weren't quite what I expected it
adolescent grew in execution I feel like
it's something that works a little bit
better on paper what I'm gonna do though
is I'm gonna wait till after I see the
movie 1 or 2 more times before I do my
spoilery review later this week and then
I'll rank all my top Marvel films this
is definitely top 5 Marvel films of all
time but I want to see it a couple more
times before I give my final ranking
just to soak it all in just because
there is so much to unpack like I said
even though it gets really nuts
it is not structured like a traditional
Marvel film I feel like the Russos made
the best version of this that it could
be there were lots of reports - about
parts of the film being cut out the
runtime being a little bit shorter for
the most part I think that 99% of people
are saying the exact same cut of the
film
I think the Disney cut it right down
under two and a half hours just from a
business perspective because so many
people are gonna be taking their
families to see this and they want
people to buy it for movie tickets for
the entire family and not just to for
the adults so I think they were a little
bit worried about families pausing at
the thought of taking children to see a
movie that was longer than two and a
half hours but don't worry the Russos
did say that there would be a crazy
amount of deleted scenes on the blu-ray
when they released that later this year
so whatever they cut out we will get to
see no matter what in for the most part
that just means that they trim scenes
down it's not like they just completely
cut out storylines from the movie so
you're still getting the version of the
movie that they originally wanted you to
see
it's just that they trimmed it just a
little bit but boy that post-credits
scene they structured the film for
maximum WTF payoff at the end so that
when you're walking out of the theater
even if you're not a comic book man
you'll be screaming but without doing
spoilers the clever thing that they did
was end on a moment that was a
cliffhanger in not a cliffhanger at the
same time so I'll explain that when I
post my spoiler review because it's sort
of like they're having their cake and
eating it too like oh we're not gonna do
a cliffhanger but it kind of is it's
more of a cliffhanger for people that
don't read the comics and I can't make
the jump to like oh you know these are
the other things that could possibly
happen with the next movie so if you're
a big comic book person your mind will
be moving at a thousand miles an hour
about what's going to happen next don't
worry we'll talk about all that stuff
this weekend so what's gonna happen next
is I'll be posting more non-spoilery
stuff tomorrow
but then on Thursday night I'll post my
post credit scene video we'll start
talking about that then I'll post my
spoiler review on Friday and then we'll
just go from there just based on what
people request like there will be a
couple of things that people want to
talk about way more than other things
but I think at the end of the day
infinity war is gonna go down as a crazy
film like it's nuts but it's the best
possible version of the end of this big
you know 10 year story that they've been
telling as it could have been there's a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video click here to
rewatch that new venom trailer and click
here for more new infinity war thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]